y más
estamos en el museo nacional de arte en
la ciudad de mexico y estamos observando
un asombroso y gran lienzo de josé maría
velasco es una imagen panorámica del
valle de mexico
la pintura es sobre la tierra y sobre la
historia de la tierra en el centro
ligeramente a la derecha vemos la ciudad
de mexico apenas se ve pero es
suficientemente claro como para divisar
las torres de la catedral de la ciudad
de mexico josé maría velasco usa la luz
y la sombra para guiar nuestra vista en
un maravilloso movimiento zigzagueante
del plano principal a la parte del fondo
a la ciudad en sí misma así que hablemos
de la forma en la que llegamos allí en
el primer plano tenemos este detalle
increíble este es un artista que tiene
mucho cuidado con los fenómenos
botánicos y meteorológicos
el estudio las plantas la geología la
formación de las nubes para obtener esta
exactitud pero nuestra vista se enfoca
en esta pequeña escena de una madre con
dos niños que parecen estar alejándose
de la ciudad caminando de regreso a la
naturaleza
esta es una sombra dramática que
comienza en la esquina inferior derecha
con la que el artista nos lleva a través
del primer plano y nos guía que nuestra
vista pase por la luz alrededor de este
precipicio que está en el primer plano y
entonces empezamos a encontrar nuestro
camino a la tierra de en medio en la que
podemos ver una estructura que está
asociada con el cerro del tepeyac en
donde está la basílica de la virgen de
guadalupe donde ella apareció
milagrosamente a juan diego en 1531 uno
de los grandes momentos espirituales uno
de los grandes lugares espirituales de
méjico esta pintura es de alguna manera
una celebración de los grandes momentos
en la historia de méxico y de sus raíces
espirituales y luego más allá de las
rutas que son parte del antiguo camino
azteca y que nos guían al corazón de la
ciudad de méxico- vemos algunos efectos
de la industrial
pero solo algunos el polvo tal vez fue
levantado por maquinaria o por carruajes
todo esto en contraste con el lago que
desaparece un lago que una vez rodeó la
ciudad que vemos a la distancia cuando
era la capital azteca pero que ha sido
dejado de lado por el creciente
desarrollo por lo que vemos este momento
transitorio no solo en términos del
desarrollo humano sino también en cuanto
a las formaciones en el cielo vemos
nubes vemos lluvia a la derecha un
balance hermoso y esos dos volcanes son
importantes en la historia de méxico son
los volcanes popocatépetl e iztaccíhuatl
que representan la relación de dos
personas dos amantes del período azteca
por lo que son importantes en la
historia de méxico aún cuando se trata
de una celebración de méxico su presente
su historia su mitología también es en
gran medida una pintura del siglo 19 se
trata de una pintura que está
profundamente relacionada con el
romanticismo de gente como john
constable en inglaterra o casper david
frederik en alemania este es un
movimiento internacional que busca
volver a la natural
en toda su grandeza la forma en la que
puede evocar el poder espiritual pero es
un momento histórico que está interesado
en el momento científico creo que ahí es
donde empiezan a salir más de las
cualidades románticas del paisaje josé
maría velasco estaba interesado en la
observación científica de la naturaleza
para hacer lo más exacto posible así que
él está pintando como un miembro de la
academia de san carlos esta institución
académica aquí en la ciudad de mexico y
su maestro es en realidad un inmigrante
italiano que está formado en la
enseñanza del paisajismo una de las
técnicas que utiliza el artista es
pintar en un estudio para que pueda
obtener el detalle exacto en condiciones
controladas pero basa su pintura en
numerosos bocetos que él hace del
paisaje y somos afortunados de tener
algunos de los bocetos que produjo en el
sendero de esta montaña y esta es una de
las numerosas pinturas que el artista
completó que muestran el valor de méxico
desde esta perspectiva y a propósito de
que estamos en la galería podemos ver
algunas de estas otras pinturas
incluyendo otra casi desde el mismo
de vista pero está desde un ángulo
ligeramente diferente un poco más alto
pero no tenemos figuras humanas en su
lugar en primer plano vemos un águila
que parece haber volado fuera de un
nopal y en méjico esto es poético podría
ser simplemente un águila volando de un
cactus pero para la historia de méxico
esto está relacionado con la historia de
la migración azteca donde terminaron
estableciendo su ciudad capital de los
titans o la moderna ciudad de méxico- en
una isla en medio del lago después de
que vieron un águila posada en un nopal
y este símbolo es el emblema central en
la bandera mexicana lo encontramos en la
moneda y sigue siendo un lazo entre el
méxico moderno y sus orígenes aztecas y
entonces como entendemos estas pinturas
de josé maría velasco como la
impartición de esta creciente urgencia
de la identidad nacional mexicana que ha
estado en curso desde la independencia
en 1821